Hắn tin vên gia là tin gia của khu ba nền đình. Đây là kì bầu cử có nhiều đêm mới trong phương tức trên khai
và nãy ngốc lực đời mới quan lý và nước cao rất lượng đại biểu.
Tờ báo rất lời chủ thế cúp hội, chủ thế khội đồng bầu cử cuốc gia trên thình bắn
nhấn mạnh cơ cấu người ứng cử, đảm bảo tính thả dịnh dậm giải của các tự lắm nhân dân
phùm miền và lĩnh vực.
Đáng chú ý, tì lệ ứng cử viên lửa đặt bố mi làm phải 3 mi bày phân chăm, trong 3 chăm chứng mi hai người
và có một chẳng tảm vi tạm ứng cử viên là người rất tập thiệu số.
Pren gia là tin gia cũng nên gia cao việc ứng dụng công nghệ thung tín trên đời số bài bàn
từ khâu lập dinh sách đến cập nhật tính chính bảo viểu.
Công chung nhận đình, hẳng tình giới tơ s của anh được tin,
về việc hẳng chục chêu cử chi Việt Nam thăm gia bảo viểu,
để lửa trọn năm trong đại biểu cuốc hội từ dành sách gần tạm chẳng ứng cử viên.
Sài tơ sến mạnh tì lệ cử chi đi bầu tại Việt Nam luôn ở mức sức cao.
Thế hiện sự quan tâm sâu sắc của người dân đối với các sự kiện chính chỉ của đất nước.
Tờ báo cũng thông tin thêm, sự kiến đến đồng thằng bốn năm nay ngàn không chặt hai mi sấu,
cũng hợi khoảng mới sẽ tiến thành phía học đấu kiến để quyết định cắt lợi dung về công tác nghiên giữ.
Sự nghĩa nhận của báo chi cốt tế đối với ngày hội nông sân đã khẩm định quy tính của Việt Nam trong việc tổ chức các sự kiện chính chỉ quy mô lớn,
đàn bảo tính qua học hiện đại và phát quyết quyền làm chủ của nhân dân trong dây đoạn phát triển mới.